or more now in today's emergency summit
in Brussels where it's hoped eurozone
leaders will reach a deal on a bailout
package for Greece earlier we spoke to
the journalist Philip pangalos in Athens
well it's going to be a crucial day
today after Prime Minister Alexis
tsipras Simpson new revised proposals
late on Sunday night improving the greek
iphone a bid to break the deadlock in
these months long talks whether it'll be
enough we're not quite sure you'll be
seeing a number of very important people
are meet them in the morning you'll be
talking to easy present young Claude
Younker it also be meeting with IMF
chief Christine Lagarde as well as your
a group chief your own dice'll bloom and
a very important man ECB chief Mario
Draghi we'll see what progress is made
as those talks if they've had a chance
to assess the Greek proposals ahead over
the special eurozone summit later in the
afternoon now it's going to be tough
because there still seems to be quite
some difference between the two sides
with the Greeks saying that the the
measures being insisted on by the
international creditors but just two or
steer for them and we'll just make their
economy contracted even more I don't
know any that the big problem is that
see prices whatever deal he does agree
on if he does agree on a deal is going
to be very tough to get through his own
Parliament at the same time time is
running out very very fast greece in a
very precarious situation the current
deal runs out as we know at the end of
the month greece has to find 1.6 billion
euros to pay outstanding money owed to
the IMF if it doesn't it risks
defaulting and as this is happening bow
and the concerns that there could be a
Greek default and they could be a Greek
exit from the single currency Greek
sailors are very nervous the Greek banks
are in a very precarious position they
are effectively on life support from the
ECB's emergency liquidity assistance
facility we know that something like
four billion euros was withdrawn last
week alone from nervous Greek so savers
there are thoughts that they might need
another 1 billion later today we don't
know how long the ECB will continue
supporting Greek banks
what's the last thing they want is
capital controls let's not forget that
the Greek economy which is contracted by
more than twenty-five percent in the
previous five years of harsh austerity
measures with an employment above twenty
six percent is back in recession so any
capital controls could affect would be a
one-way street the economy and track for
the unemployment already above twenty
six percent would go up higher it's a
very precarious position very tense
times of course there is knee you summit
at the end of the week but we don't know
if Greek banks can survive that long
Philip pangalos they're speaking to us
earlier from Athens